[Music]
my name is Lucien I'm one of the PM's
working on our village strata product
that's now called enthis migrate and I'm
joined today with two other gentlemen
that will come on stage later on we have
our architect and technical lead for
this product low need that's here with
us and we have David who is the product
manager for service mesh and east you as
well so during this the next 50 minutes
what we like to tell you about is enthis
migrate what it is and how we will
enable you to migrate on-premise type of
VMs workloads to cloud native and how to
take you to the gk journey so that's the
goal of what we want to achieve in the
next 50 minutes together and we'll be
I'll be leading the first part of our
talk and then we'll go over and deep
dive before I start what I'd like to
clarify is naming and what things are
because we made some announcements two
days ago at the keynote and what I
wanted to make sure everyone understands
it is that the product called anthos
migrate now that we decide to call that
way is actually our villa strata
technology that's a Google product and
it's the same thing so if some of you
are familiar with villa strata migration
of VM to VM lift and shift now we have a
new functionality where we also migrate
to containers to GK and both of these
those strata functions are called anthos
migrate so it's the same thing and I
hope this clears it up here's the agenda
for next 48 minutes I'll go over first
some of the whys why we want to do what
we're doing what are the goals and
what's the reason of our technology then
I'll go on to product overview after
that I'll hand it off to David who will
be talking about sir
management and finally we'll have low
need that will go over the architecture
so more technically Leonid will explain
what's happening with the migration
process and he will guide you on the
architecture deep dive of the product
all right so without further ado why why
do we want to move VM workloads to run
as containers on GK why is it compelling
first of all migration is a difficult
task migration is hard most enterprise
enterprises trying to migrate realize
how difficult it is they face delays
budgets and stuff like that so it's a
hard thing to do and when we pull on
different surveys it's top of mind for
customers and actually I'll do a poll
here in the room can I get a raise of
hand on how many of you would like to
move to the cloud this room okay about a
third how about how many of you want to
move to gke okay MGK on-premise some
okay so for those of you that want to
move i hope this session makes sense and
for the other ones i'd like to take you
on board so you understand our
technology so when these topics come top
of mind you know best what Google can
offer you to migrate you and take you to
that journey so challenge is it's hard
at the scale you have data centers and
you have workloads you have thousands of
VMs that you may need to move you have
multi different places different
locations and you're wondering what to
aggregate the applications sometimes run
on multiple places which app do you
select which one can you move and how
then do you start doing it and it's
complex it's also the applications are
complex and you have to understand
what's happening behind there and then
lastly the risk we oftentimes talk about
migration but we don't often talk about
rolling back what happens if you start
to migrate and things don't go well
well you'd like to go back to your
initial state without losing data so you
can roll back and then figure it out and
try again later with our technology we
can provide you that back and forth at
any time so you can run on premise
migrate if something happens you can
come back and we have multiple ways of
doing that that migration so why now do
we want to modernize our workloads to
containers well there's there's two two
main things one is we have customers and
about a third in this room knows this
that want to modernize legacy
applications so the idea is well I'd
like to move certain parts to the cloud
because it's more cost efficient it
makes more sense it will be closer to a
development environment and I'm
developing some new app on the cloud and
I'd like to move some legacy apps over
there as well to be able to interact
with my applications are running on the
cloud I'd like to modernize my
application management lifecycle and
have a consistent way to do maintenance
patching and so forth so that's one the
second one on this slide is well G K so
G ke is are offering for kubernetes and
a lot of our customers love G K and so
that's a compelling reason to move to
Google or to GCP in general and so we
can take you to that framework from a
traditional enterprise vm place to take
you to educate once you're there you'll
see the benefits of jke so management of
your images OS interaction with logging
interaction with service mashes and east
yo and so those are things we'll talk
about today in terms of your benefits as
when you move to the cloud before I
forget we also have a Dory today open so
if any of you have a question at any
time feel free to raise your hand or
type a question on the dory and we'll
come back to the Dory we have along here
that
monitoring our dory and we will get back
to your questions so we talked about you
know why we're doing it now why is it
hard why is it hard to move it from a VM
environment to GK specifically well when
you have a legacy app to moving to a
micro-services environment you have to
rewrite it in a modern way and
oftentimes go from a obviously stateful
type of application to think about how
you're going to make it stateless and so
that is actually really a difficult
thing to do you have to rebuild your
application okay
many of the old applications don't have
that type of knowledge of application
logic and just cannot go into being
stateless so it's it's something hard
and oftentimes it's not possible however
your new applications that you're
developing
they are modern-day interact they're
containerized and so then comes the
point of well I'd like these new
applications that I'm deploying to also
be able to interact with the other ones
and to have a consistent way to manage
my infrastructure my workloads by being
by being on containers on in container
framework and this is why second point
is why not just do a lift and shift or
just move a VM to be a VM moving to the
cloud you can do that and we offer that
technology we know how to do it at scale
we have customers moving thousands and
thousands of VMs and lift and shift
where the sources of yem and the
destination is a VM but the new thing
that here we're talking about is the
sources of yam and the destination is a
container okay
and finally when you're there basically
you know it's it's us adapting to your
journey to your environment and how can
we help you going to a modern framework
on containers and at the same time
enable you to move these legacy up and
still keep the lights on for these apps
to run but being managed
in the modern infrastructure so with
that I'm going to go ahead and move and
talk about our product overview so what
is then those migrate how does it work
and then will will move further on the
next topic so first I'd like to ask in
the room how many of you know kubernetes
can I get a raise up in majority okay
great
so we'll go we'll go quickly over this
one portable open source management
platform allowing you to scale to run
basically to orchestrate your containers
and to run them with the pub with policy
declarative model and be able to run on
various clusters various environments so
it's our initially our internal systems
obviously run on kubernetes and now it's
where we do it with manage to Burnett is
gke where we actually take care of
managing the kernel for you providing
you upgrade security patches fixes and
so our sre teams operate the management
of the kernel and OS for you when you
are on GK versus running kubernetes by
yourself on an open source model right
so as we know GK I'll move forward so at
this point we're at a place where you
have applications hopefully there are
VMs in a datacenter you know the value
of GK and you want to modernize these
apps or you want these apps to be able
to run in that new modern environment so
then what you do then comes this product
and those migrate ok and here is at a
glance what we do we you start and the
way to read this slide will go on the
left hand side of the slide I'd like you
to read it from bottom up ok so at the
bottom what you see is that we have
different sources of environments you
can be on-premise you can be on a public
cloud and you have as a starting point a
virtual machine
your destination is up on this slide
which is just the GCP platform where you
end up is basically
containers running on gke and then you
have other services service mesh that
come and attach themselves to that so
all the ecosystem of the GCP platform
come and then can interact with your gk
cluster once you've done that move okay
so we can do vmware we can do physical
bare metal we can do other cloud type of
migration and the source is a virtual
machine okay
here is how this works and for you to
understand isis anthos migrate there's
two things that you need to understand
one is understand GK and understand GCP
and this is new this can be new when you
are in an enterprise or a VM environment
and you're moving to the cloud so one
aspect to know is containers and GK and
how GK works and the second part is the
enters migrate those strata technology
and so we intersect that at these two
end and the way we've designed this is
to give you the journey and experience
of kubernetes so how do we start the
journey you're an user and you're you're
you're over here and you want to go on
containers so the way you will do that
is basically you're going to do a
deployment policy you will have a llamo
file which is kubernetes and you will
tell gke
that you want to start a migration so
actually you start your migration by
talking to GK e versus you know going on
your on-premise environment and so you
push the yellow file and then what GK
will do GK integrates with our enters
migrate technology and then we start the
migration of the VM so you have these
VMs that you see here that are running
in your data center and we've received
from kubernetes from GK we receive the
instructions to migrate and then villa
strata and those migrate starts the
migration so you are you have these two
blue VMs that are running on your data
center and when we move
is over here you end up with two
containers so I did a one on one mapping
just to show you the example the visual
example where you have two VMs running
on premise and the end result is two
containers running on GK and it's all
orchestrated by GK and so that's really
important too important concept to know
now with that I'll tell you a little bit
more under the hood in terms of how we
enable this migration so I'll just move
to this slide we have basically here a
our villa strata and enthis my grade
technology resides into two places one
is on premise we have a villa strata
appliance which is a VM running on one
of your V centers which is basically the
bar backend and we have an ESX plug-in
so I'll plug in for VMware that will be
basically give you the manageability and
the interaction with the virtual
machines over there so that's one part
of the deployment so you install that on
your own premise environment number two
on the cloud we have running our
management software for Vale strata so
install that through marketplace you
install it as a VM running and you
connect to your own Prem between the two
we assume that you have IP connectivity
between your on-premise environment and
your GCP cluster that can be achieved by
a V PC that can be achieved by an
interconnect but you have to have IP
connectivity between your two
environments okay we create then a local
cache on the cloud and what we do is now
listen to this we have a VM running and
you start the migration in five to ten
minutes depending if it's Linux or
Windows your new environment will be up
and running on the cloud the way we do
it is we start
the new VM or the new container so I'm
talking at two use cases either the VM
to VM or VM to container we start up the
new we fire up the new container for
example the data initially is still
residing on your own premise and is
being streamed over your IP connection
to the new environment and that data is
getting get is gettin cached locally the
cache grows and you can start testing
your application you can start using it
right away
you don't need to wait for all the data
all the disks to be migrated for you to
know if your application will start
working on the cloud and we achieve that
with our streaming anthos migrated
technology okay
and you benefit from that technology
whether you do VM to VM migration or VM
2 containers migration if things don't
go well you can roll back we also have
ways for you to do testing so if you are
running production in your environment
we can actually make a copy and get you
to test a clone of that VM on the cloud
so it's less disruptive and then we give
you the way to migrate at waves later on
production environments so if you want
to migrate hundreds thousands of yams
you can do that on a schedule with
automation tools that we provide so
that's how the whole migration is
working under the hood okay next now
that you are with containers for example
where do you see your logs so on your VM
initially you go and you have to look at
log files and understand error messages
and so forth we have integrated the logs
from your VMs with stack driver with the
GK dashboard and more importantly and
David will be telling you about this
with service management
okay and so you basically can see your
logs
as you would see logs from you know you
see your log outputs here in in the
stack driver output and so you can
interact with API is with monitoring
management tools if you have but it is a
modern GCP native display same goes with
the gk dashboard okay you can see that
what your app is doing how much CPU it's
using and so forth now the next point is
well what can you migrate to containers
what really can you do if you're if you
are ready to migrate your VMs to
containers
what we're doing is basically Linux
operating systems today we don't support
yet Windows Windows because we don't
have Windows on containers so it has to
be Linux it has to be Red Hat sent to us
SUSE Ubuntu those are the main operating
systems Tomcat Apache WebSphere WebLogic
JBoss type of middleware applications
databases so all of these legacy type of
stateful workloads you can migrate to GK
certain things that we don't yet do
because we what we announced was our
beta that is that we're working on now
on this product we don't want you yet to
move production we don't want you to
move sensitive data because we're on a
on a private beta at the moment and
another thing we don't do is high
performance databases such as I do big
data type of workloads and you know here
for you know transparency purposes we've
outlined the things we support we don't
support keep in mind that the product is
evolving you know roadmap and so forth
so if there are things that you'd like
to get come talk to us at the booth come
meet us today talk to your field to your
field representatives and we can work
with you to prioritize things this is
just to give you a framework so you can
understand if it's something that's
applicable to you right away
with that I'd like to give you a little
demo and just so you can visualize the
product so let's go and try to play this
recording so while this loads I just
want to prepare you
it's a CRM application so it's basically
going to be a a web app that has a
database and customer base CRM and it's
going to be two VMs so I have it running
out to different virtual machines on
VMware one is a database and one is the
web server and application and will
migrate these two VMs from on-premise to
GK ok and here we're going to play this
and we can spend a lot more time with
you if you stop by our booth we can show
you the demo live here for purpose of
time and everything I just want to play
a recording so I just get things going
so you see the concepts but then we can
spend more time on the live demo so as
you see we have as I said two VMs one is
running on sent OS and the other one is
running on Susie so I have two different
operating system as a start and that's
my CRM app running on premise so two VMs
to us as I can log in and what you see
here when I log in on the local IP is
that the look of that then I have a GK
cluster called demo which is running a
specific version of GK and I have
basically a y'know file remember I told
you that we start the migration from
llamó and from with from kubernetes so
we have a file where we say look this is
the VM number we want to use streaming
for Villa strata migration technology
and we want to do here a test lon for
example we point to a persistent disk
and we define the app name and the way
we'll look once it's migrated on the on
the destination environment so we're
going to go ahead and execute the llamo
file it's at the very bottom here we do
a cube code I'll apply and basically
what you see we refresh services and
workloads here is basically now - you
can see the two nodes
app and database and you can see the
services we have a load balancer with a
local with an IP on the cloud and we log
in onto that IP and it's the same app
now that app has moved and is running as
containers on GK then we go ahead and we
enable East you as an add-on on to our
cluster now when we do that basically we
can go in stack driver and we can see
data we can see the graphs and a lot
more things we can do is going to be
what David is going to talk to you about
next which is service mesh which will be
added functions of what you do once you
are on gke
and you've migrated our our application
so with that Dave I'd like to call you
up and take it away for us and I'll put
it back in presentation mode so so first
of all thank you Lucien so I just
actually want to recap because one of
the things that's really amazing there
is I don't know whether you just realize
what you've witnessed which are
literally witnessed a VM application
on-premise migrating live directly to
gke so I think that's actually pretty
amazing personally I think that's
actually gives you an opportunity and
this is something that you can do while
your applications are running so I think
that's actually a pretty pretty big
thing everyone you know when Lucien
asked before around the number of people
who understand or know what GK is you
know those are very very large number of
people so the other thing that we talk
about a lot from a from a Google
perspective is sto and service mesh so
sto is an open source project
I was founded primarily by IBM and
Google there is a large number of
contributors now Cisco VMware Red Hat
there are a large number of people
contributing to sto and we're getting a
lot of community support so this is
actually something that we're actually
investing quite heavily in and we think
this is a natural extension for both
kubernetes and non-cuban of these
environments but also it gives you the
away it gives you ability to do things
from a service management perspective
that you you know may not necessarily it
it reduces the need for you to
instrument your code and you can take
advantage
those things effectively out of the box
so one of the things that we talked
about would be let's do the migration
that you just saw to do that into a
service mesh enabled
Jiki cluster by doing that you can
actually take advantage of some of the
service management capabilities that you
get from a service mesh from day one so
there are three main tenants around
service mesh so if I look at the three
key benefits that service mesh provide
its effectively uniform observability it
is operational agility this is the
ability to migrate traffic through
circuit braking retries within your
environment and then policy-driven
security so this is from a micro
services environment on all your nice
freshly migrated VM workloads into
containers you can start applying these
tenants straightaway out of the box so
let's drill into these just a little bit
and then I'll do a little bit of a
demonstration on service management so
one of the things that a service mesh
provides is it provides uniform metrics
and flow logs across your entire
environment when we deploy a container
into kubernetes we use a SCO sidecar
injector to basically automatically
inject a sidecar co-located in every pod
associated with that service the
advantage of doing that is in a language
agnostic way I now get a very consistent
set of metrics and flow logs through my
entire environment I can use them as
golden signals I can use them to get an
understanding of these service
dependencies that I have within my
environment these service dependencies
can literally give you a way to
understand how your services are
connected this gives you and this is
actually based on the traffic flows that
is going through your mesh the last
thing you can do is now I have these
really really nice uniformed a
consistent flow logs and metrics I can
use them as my golden signals to set up
a solos
on those services I can look at the the
service dependencies to understand what
my critical customer user journey is
with respect to what's going to impact
my end SLA to my customers the other key
thing that we actually look at here is
with within a service match is the
ability to add agility so there's two
things here one one here is around the
ability to shift traffic or split
traffic canary would be a good example
of this I can move based on a waiting a
certain amount of traffic from one
service to a newer version of that
service and Canaria there was a talk
earlier this this week where a customer
using sto has increased the number of
rollouts from around one a day to one
target to 15,000 this year and the main
reason they're able to do that is there
now incrementally releasing multiple
times a day in very small increments
that's doing two things but it's
actually reducing the risk because every
change is incremental and they've got
very fine-grained controls and how they
can marry those releases this is
shortening the time it takes for them to
get their changes out to their customers
which is really important the other key
thing that sto provides is the ability
to do things like circuit breaking I can
do retries I can build this into the
infrastructure itself so if my VM
application that I've just migrated to
containers didn't have any of that sort
of capability built into it I can now
start picking up these capabilities just
from the service mesh infrastructure the
last thing is around security so with
with with issue or service mesh I can
effectively apply a identity based
security model between my services so I
can migrate my services and I can
actually pick that up straight away I
can also start looking at that
interconnect and start getting security
insights so let's just take two minutes
and have a quick look at what that
actually looks like
so I actually have a micro service
application running and these are the
services that are actually operational
within within the actual mesh let me
just make that can everyone see that
okay I didn't need to make a little bit
bigger it's ok alright so the other so
what I can actually do here is I can I
can go through and I can quickly look at
the actual topology associated with this
particular environment so I understand
the service dependencies I can highlight
a specific service and understand the
actual traffic that's traversing this
environment follows to click on that
service I can go to the service
dashboard and look at that particular
service you'll notice on this particular
service I do not actually have I have
not said any SL O's one of the things
you'll also notice is I automatically
have a security recommendation so they
this particular service
I have not enabled n TLS it is the flow
logs and metrics has given me that
information and it's given me now
recommendation of how I can increase the
security posture of my environment so
these are the things that the service
mesh can provide for you straight out of
the box and this can now be applied
directly to those VM workloads that have
been migrated directly into GK I get
very consistent these nice flow logs and
metrics associated with the services
that I've now just migrated I can start
doing things like set SOS on these
services so setting an SLO very simple
pushing through selecting say
availability would be an example of so
low money five point four actually that
would be pretty impressive you can
actually do this based on a rolling
period of time or a calendar period of
time depending on whether you're setting
something up more for internal or more
to match a business objective windowing
can also be optionally added
respect to plying now a a an alert
associated with a smaller period of time
and it would literally just be as simple
as applying that and now I actually have
an SLO said for that particular service
so that's just kind of a little bit of a
you know if you think about again what
Lucien demonstrated he migrated VM
workloads straight to kubernetes if you
migrate those VM based workloads into a
kubernetes cluster that has service
management or service machine abled this
then just be effectively just works out
of the box so at this point I'd actually
like to pause and invite Leon up to talk
a little bit more in technical detail
around anthos migrate and I will hand it
over
thank you thank you David so I like to
give you a glimpse of inner insides of
how it works where we're heading to this
is very young product so we are just
starting it's a long journey and I want
to show you a bit what we doing now and
what we're doing next and but before
that but before that I like to give you
a little bit of history back to the
history lane so let's let's think of the
developer application developer that
that work on application five years ago
maybe ten years ago right so he was
writing code and then he wanted to run
it in his related way probably bundled
with content some runtime like Java
Python maybe and he wanted to put it
somewhere and the best place to put it
in his railway was VM and this was
convenient
powered by V no words was extremely
popular so every application that you
write ended up being
with this with this stack on the left
side and you only need application maybe
two three services around it but you
were getting the virtual hardware that
you need to manage and network and disks
an operating system with caramel and
stuff and all the infrastructure that
you need to accumulate like vlogs and
security policies and users that can
access it so all this is a good start
but then you starting to get more of
those and specifically the painful the
dolls application dilution mesh and
mentioned small or midsize stateful
application maybe simple database web
middle fear apps they started to
accumulated this can be written apps for
some on the some enterprise or may be of
the Shelf applications sorry that you
that you manage and this is very very
painful become very very painful
now imagine today you are container
developers or you can develop your
application packages in the doctor
container run it with kubernetes so
today if you develop a new one you have
a way doing that but what will you will
do with all these leftovers and this is
very very painful rewrite so what we
wanted to do is phased approach or face
journey for those legacy applications to
get to the modern modern way and there
are not number of stops in the middle
and these talks can help you benefit
from some of the ecosystem maybe not all
of this and then you can benefit from
more and more so the first one the first
scope that the one that you also
actually saw on the demo that we to the
application we didn't change anything
for this application but we peeled away
all the low level stuff that is not
required for this application to
function I mean it's required but it's
not must to be the same stuff in the VM
right so we we do be we're always kernel
and drivers now it's provided
container freight containers
orchestration framework we took away
login with the way we're networking
networking is now handled by kubernetes
storage and we live application and the
services that you may have maybe some
cron jobs for this application to run so
this is first step that allows you to
get into the stage when you manage the
kubernetes leverage all these good
features that you have but it's still
not not at the end of the journey the
next part next bar is going to this
stage where we want to take this upper
part of the VM and split it further
maybe some application will be rewritten
some of our application will be just
breaking down to the application and the
data and maybe some will sound
obligation will be left as is because
you're don't find it cost effective to
invest in them and so this is the
journey that we follow and the better
we'll cover mostly this part and this
part will come preview right pretty much
after that
so this is one aspect the second aspect
which is also very important is how you
doing your journey so we we focused on
all the demo and announcements we
focused on getting were close from being
where to the G key right but basically
there are two dimensions that you need
to know to handle one is migrating
things from remote location to another
location can be either cloud can be
doing were again on trend data center
and maybe you don't need to migrate at
all if you're moving from VMware to G
key on Prem you don't need to migrate
the data the data is already there right
so this dimension um we want dimensional
to is basically moving from the VM to
the container so we build product in a
way and a built architecture in a way
that
you can do any of those transitions
independently we can get you
of course the quick way this one when
you move from VMware to Jiki and cloud
getting all the benefits but you can go
either way you can first move to GC VM
and then decide to containerize this VM
and so on
and this is very important and that both
of those are handled by the product and
different types and different places on
the roadmap when we go there but but
this is important flexibility that you
want to do and especially with
kubernetes when you have the storage
obstructions so from kubernetes
perspective right you consuming storage
and storage can do remote or can be
local right if you consuming storage and
then running your workloads container it
doesn't matter you want to use these
kubernetes obstructions to hide the
storage location okay so this is just a
recap small recap what happened in the
in the demo just to give you a replay so
we started whooshing water presented
corporate user starting with the VMS on
Prem and connection to them then we
moved those VM to be in containers and
Jiki we used we started to use
networking of kubernetes so at this
point application were connecting to the
database by is this dns name and the
service and right now it's pod so it can
be have any IP you don't need to manage
IP anymore and we have a load balancer
to get us outside access and then and
then once those are containers you can
see the logs you can see the all the
benefits from the east EO and and other
things that David show you the one thing
that the Lucian mention as well is that
we
do have a technology a couple of years
now when we want to we can migrate
storage from remote locations to cloud
and we want to leverage this technology
when we use when you remove storage for
containers and when we move VMs -
containers so we have the same
infrastructure that can bring storage
from remote locations to the workloads
no matter if were close our VMs or
containers and this is how the product
is built and again you can you can use
it to migrate first VMs be em and then
containerized or can go you can go
directly to there
we're talking a lot about storage why
it's so important this is where caching
and latest optimizations and
deduplication all the things that the
storage layers gives you those strata
storage layer gives you they come into
play and it's the same optimization that
we use for containers and VMs and this
this is basically what gives you the
ability to test something or to run
something in couple of minutes because
you cannot move
terabytes of data in couple of minutes
so let's get another level down of how
this works on the kubernetes side so
quick quick show of hands who is
familiar with CSI it's less so I won't
go to the CSI here it's a lots of
lectures about that csi's container
storage interface something that became
GA in kubernetes 113 basically this is
one of the things that allows you to
abstract the storage implementation from
the orchestration so Cabernets will
orchestrate the workload creation and
will orchestrate the volume provisioning
volume attachment and then you will be
as a driver as the provider of the
storage you will be providing the
implementation for that so what will
happen when you deploy this yeah
evolution show you show you you actually
trigger the activity from kubernetes
which says okay I need to schedule this
pod on this node and need to make sure
that this node has access to storage and
you asked me for the storage of this
type so I need provisioning so this
point kubernetes goes to the storage
driver and ask me okay Loki I need to
provision the storage
this can be native storage driver for
some source vendor it can be native
storage driver for GC persistent disk or
in our case of the streaming as well as
try the control plane we basically says
look if I haven't need a provision
volume I'm exposing the storage of this
VM from on-premise or other cloud to his
plaster so cool
so Cabernets heavy volume is provisioned
now he decide which pod to scale should
be used which no should be used to run
pod and then it's come an attachment so
he connect this this node to the storage
back-end Mouse relevant volumes and at
this point the the workload the trans
consume this storage again being it
remote or local what's important in that
system so it's fully integrated with
kubernetes abstraction it's means that
if you want just to my greatest storage
and you don't want to migrate your VM
just you want you may be already having
my sequel container a my sequel image
that you want to use the only con you
want to move the data then you will do
the same so you will attach the storage
to the existing container and it will
benefit from the same from the same
streaming and compression technology and
last what you can also do with the
storage and this is something that we're
also providing this is what we call
optimized attics they do data extraction
or
selective data extractions so you can we
provide the job in the kubernetes
cluster again fully managed by
kubernetes fully obstructed by
kubernetes obstruction that can take
your streaming storage and extract part
of the file so part of the data that you
want for example you only want your my
sequel database data right so this will
fetch this storage in a streaming manner
and efficient with all the optimization
and it will it will deploy it to the
storage of your choosing it can be
native cloud storage you can be storage
vendor that that's the transient cloud
and this is also a foundation of what we
call the next phase so this is the same
technology will then be used to extract
your applications so let's say you have
multiple services running on the same VM
and you want to extract some of them so
we'll extract part part of the data will
go here part of the data will go there
and this will be the same component
doing this job okay so with that I'll
heading back solution for a quick
wrap-up Thank You Lenny so what did we
learn well hopefully I hope that you
understand first of all that
modernization is no longer something
where it means you have to rewrite
everything from scratch and it means
that if you want to go there
we're here to help you on this journey
with moving those those application on a
modern environment to I hope you
understand that state stateful apps can
actually run now in GK without and you
you no need for writing them again it's
kind of the same as the first point but
and then number three this can be
directly done from on-premise to the
cloud and you can be up and running in
minutes now one thing to to remember is
you we don't have to migrate you
directly to containers and to the cloud
if your on-premise
we can do it in two steps we can move
you to the cloud on the VM get you
comfortable and then move that VM to a
container okay so we can meet you in
your journey where you are and this
comes back to some of the questions on
the dory today where one question was
well how about Windows can I use anthos
migrate for Windows well what we can do
today with Antos migrate for Windows is
VM to VM migrations so we can get you to
the cloud running as a VM and when we
have support for Windows on gke
hopefully later this year then we can
migrate that VM into a container number
two another question on the Dory was
well is the estrada requirement of
anthos migrate anthos migrate is villa
strata it's the same thing you install
villa strata and you can do VM to VM
migration and now you can do VM to gke
migration so hopefully that clears it up
I've put some links on the deck so if
you download this you have the list of
all our resources public documentation
we have a couple of other sessions one
more this afternoon that will be
interesting I think the other ones have
passed but you can watch the recordings
we're at the booth all day stop by the
infrastructure and modernization booth
to talk to us we can do live demos talk
further on your environment and finally
in the last 10 seconds just to let you
know give us feedback what you liked
what you didn't like if you want us to
come back again and talk more if you
don't want us to see us again let us
know but we really take it seriously so
thank you very much and have a good
conference
[Applause]
[Music]
you